(upbeat music)
- Hey everybody I'm Kevin Grace
from the Kelly Clarkson's Show,
I'm the creative designer here on the show
and it is our favorite time of the year.
Well, second favorite,
favorite is always Christmas,
but our second favorite time
of the year is Halloween.
Come take a look inside
and see what we're doing.
(upbeat music)
It's of course that time of
the year, it's Halloween time.
And we finally got approval
for this year's big Halloween show,
"Ghostbusters Afterlife."
So in this story in the movie,
a lot of it takes place in a barn.
Things are hidden away for years,
so Steven's created the
inside look of the barn
for the whole set.
- Hey I am David,
and I'm the production
designer for the specials
for Kelly Clarkson Show.
My job is to change our set
into this Ghostbusters' world.
- We've gotta build the set in a way
that makes it look like we've
got a whole bunch of stuff
that's been sitting around for years.
If we're lucky, we'll
hopefully get the actor one,
which is the car from
the Ghostbusters movie.
So that would be amazing to have on set.
You guys ready?
- Ready.
- [David] Let's get to it.
- Let do it.
(upbeat music)
(soft music)
- We are getting ready
for our Halloween episode.
It's one of the most
exciting times a year.
- We are working on something really good.
You guys are gonna love it.
- So I'm really hype
about this year songs.
This year we're doing
Ghostbusters, Ray Parker Jr.
And we're gonna
(man whooping)
have all of our creepy sound and guitar,
little, a little personal touch on it.
It's something I've wanted to
do for about 30 years, now.
- This is gonna be dope.
(upbeat music)
- It's gonna be spooky.
(man laughs)
- Hey, today's the big
day here at Stage One,
Halloween is going in.
Let's check it out.
(upbeat music)
All right so as you can see,
everything is happening on the set.
We've got the stage here, our art team,
our art director David.
Everybody is here, all hands on deck,
things are happening and
the big secret surprise,
is about to roll in stage,
just in few minutes.
- There's a surprise coming.
This is the surprise I was talking about.
(upbeat music)
- [David] So Jason what
are you about to do?
- I'm about to drive the Ecto-1!
About to get this thing on stage for,
you know, Kelly's Halloween Show.
- [David] How do you feel?
- I mean this is an honor honestly.
I mean, when can you really
say you drove this thing?
(upbeat music)
- The walls are in, the car is in now,
it's time to start dressing the set.
(upbeat music)
So sunflowers are a thing on set,
of course Kelly's favorite flower.
So it just made sense
to have these old rusty,
huge outdoor sunflowers
in this barn space.
(upbeat music)
You guys mind, how is this looking?
(all laughing)
Everyone's exhausted.
(upbeat music)
- It's everything I thought we
would be able to create, Ari?
- Sick.
(men laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Oh it's the Halloween show come on in,
come on in to my spooky show.
(upbeat music)
- Gozer's ready.
(woman laughing)
- [David] Reveal of the costume.
- We're ready for Ghostbusters.
I am looking forward
to the Halloween show,
I get the bust some ghosts.
I love Ghostbusters, who
doesn't love Ghostbusters?
This is really close to my face.
(woman laughs)
Let's go do it.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Welcome to Halloween at
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
When the ghosts come knocking,
who are you gonna call?
- Ghost Busters.
- I love this audience.
Give it up for my band y'all
with that classic Ray Parker Jr song.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
- Hey I'm Ernie, Winston Zeddemore,
and I'm here to bust some ghosts.
- Oh come on, I can't.
- I got you kelly.
(crowd cheering)
- What's up everyone I'm Megan Trainor
and I'm ready to hunt some ghosts
on the Kelly Clarkson Show, watch out!
- Give it up for fellow buster
of ghosts, Meghan Trainor.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
- Hi I'm Mckenna Grace and
I'm absolutely all decked out
and ready to celebrate Halloween,
in this lovely little
step up marshmallow mum.
(crowd cheering)
- Please welcome Mckenna Grace.
(upbeat music)
- Happy Halloween.
The amazing thing about Ghostbusters,
it came out and it was number one
and then it just stayed around.
And five years later, 10 years later-
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- 20 years later, people
were dressing up and-
- [Kelly] It's a classic.
- It's yeah, it's just truly amazing.
- How we all doing down there?
- Yeah great.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
- Today we're giving the cheque
to the person in the audience
with the best, most
creative, homemade costume,
Jennifer!
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
Special thanks to our arts
department, led by David Eckert,
this looks amazing.
And Kevin Grace, y'all amazing.
And costume and wardrobe
supervisor Earl Nickelson,
Alyssia Rendal and their team.
I love my team y'all, they're so awesome,
this is such a fun show.
We came, we saw, we kicked
it's butt, happy Halloween.